نبال فك المتحدثة باسم
جمعية الهلال الأحمر الفلسطيني تنضم إلينا مباشرة
من مدينة رالا في الضفة الغربية نبال عظيم
وجودكم معنا توزيع المساعدات الذي
تم تسليمه يوم السبت كان قطرة في
محيط اشرحوا لنا الظروف التي
تعيشها غزة والكارثة
الإنسانية  هذا ما
يتكشف، لذلك تعرضت أم غزة طوال 16 يومًا
لقصف مكثف حيث
تعرضت المباني السكنية والمدارس والمستشفيات وحتى أماكن العبادة لقصف مكثف.
الوضع في غزة مفجع للغاية
وغامر، ولا يمكن حتى
وصف مليوني فلسطيني الآن
إنهم عالقون إما في منازلهم أو في
المدارس أو حتى في المستشفيات حيث
يحتمون دون الحصول على الماء الغذائي
وحتى بدون كهرباء. كل هؤلاء
المدنيين الفلسطينيين هم حاجة ملحة
لكل حاجة إنسانية أساسية
وهي الغذاء والماء فقط، وهذا هو
ما يحدث حرفيًا.  يحدث الناس الآن
يقضون أيام دون أن يملكوا كسرة
خبز أما المستشفيات
للأسف المستشفيات مكتظة
تعمل بكامل طاقتها أه
بدأ ينفد الدواء
والمستلزمات الطبية وكذلك الوقود
اللازم للحصول على الكهرباء لأنها
تماما  الاعتماد على
المولدات الاحتياطية لتوفير الكهرباء علاوة على
ذلك حتى اللحظة خرجت سبع مستشفيات
عن الخدمة إما بسبب
القصف أو بسبب نفاد
الإمدادات وكذلك خرج 24 مركزاً طبياً
عن الخدمة لدينا حوالي
24 مستشفى  الآن تحت التهديد
بالقصف في أي ثانية بسبب
أوامر الإخلاء الإسرائيلية، أحدهم هو مستشفانا،
مستشفى آل
تلقينا تهديدات بإخلاء
مستشفى آل على الفور لأنه سيتم
قصفه حتى
الأمس إذا تمكنت من التدخل إذا تمكنت من ذلك.  يمكنني
فقط القفز في شاحنة TR 20 نابال إذا كان بإمكاني
القفز هناك لأنك
وصلت إلى نقطة أريد أن أسألك
عنها إسرائيل تدعو إلى
إخلاء المستشفى الخاص بك
مستشفى آل أه من الواضح أنه يعالج مئات
المرضى لك  لقد تقدمنا ​​باستئنافين
دون جدوى ما الذي
سيحدث نعم كما ذكرت، لقد
ناشدنا المجتمع الدولي
لأكثر من أسبوع لوقف
أمر الإخلاء لمجرد أننا لا نملك
الوسائل لإخلاء المستشفى الموجود
لدينا.  500 مريض يتواجدون حاليًا في
المستشفى، العديد منهم في وحدة العناية المركزة،
معظم الأشخاص في
وحدة العناية المركزة، معظم المرضى يعانون من
إصابات خطيرة وهم أطفال
تعرضوا للقصف بسبب القصف الإسرائيلي،
ليس لدينا وسائل الإخلاء
إذا كنا سنقوم بالإخلاء، فهذا
يعني مقتل المريض، وليس
نحن فقط، حتى الذين ذكروا أن
أوامر الإخلاء للمستشفيات من
المستحيل تنفيذها
وتشكل عقوبة الإعدام للمرضى،
لماذا يستهدف جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي مستشفاك
كما قلت  ليس مستشفانا فقط هو
حوالي 24 مستشفى في المنطقة المستهدفة
حيث حذرت إسرائيل الناس في
غزة والشمال بإخلاء
أنفسهم إلى الجنوب، هذه القرارات
أوامر الإخلاء ليس فقط
للمدنيين الفلسطينيين بل تشمل أيضًا
المستشفيات التي يبلغ عددها حوالي 25 مستشفى
فقط واحدة من هذه المستشفيات.  منهم في الجنوب، والـ
24 الباقون موجودون في غزة وقد
أصدرت إسرائيل أوامر الإخلاء هذه مما أجبر
المستشفيات على إخلاء غزة،
وهو ما قلته كما قلت وجميع
المنظمات الدولية حتى نحن قلنا
مرارًا وتكرارًا أننا لا نملك الوسائل للإخلاء
هذا مستحيل
سيعرض حياة مرضانا للخطر مع الأخذ
في الاعتبار أن في
مستشفانا الآن لدينا أكثر من 12 ألف
مدني معظمهم من الأطفال
والنساء الذين لم يتمكنوا من
إجلاء أنفسهم إلى الجنوب بسبب
القصف المستمر ولا توجد
طريقة  بالنسبة لهم للذهاب لأنه لا يوجد
وسائل نقل، تدمير كامل للبنية
التحتية والطرق، لذا قاموا
ببيع اللاجئين إلى أقرب
مستشفى، لقد أتوا إلى مستشفانا كمأوى
آمن لهم ولكن
لسوء الحظ ليس هذا هو الحال
لأننا الآن تحت التهديد  من
التعرض للقصف في أي لحظة بسبب
التهديدات الإسرائيلية المستمرة بقصف
مستشفى آل مطالبين بالإخلاء الفوري،
لا يمكننا حتى القيام بذلك
كمنظمة إنسانية، لا يمكننا تعريض
حياة مرضانا للخطر